let's end this deception that somehow if
you quit the EU jobs won't be at risk
it is deceiving people to pretend that
we can leave the EU quickly you and jobs
wouldn't be at risk indeed our analysis
shows that in the services sector alone
400,000 jobs could be at risk
and these aren't numbers on a trading
screen or an accountants graph they are
people's livelihoods their ability to
support their family their ability to
live out their dreams and aspirations
and that is what is on the ballot paper
when we vote in this referendum I cannot
and will not tell the British people how
they should vote on this but I do want
to give you some of my opinions I think
it's very important that people make
decisions with their eyes open okay it
is my opinion there is a terrible deal
for the British economy and jobs
okay the uncertainty on June 24th and
imagine this on June 24th we will wake
up having a vote and if that vote is to
leave leave the EU I will have to have
teams of people storing on what that
means we won't know what it means is the
wide range of outcomes but even the best
outcome in my opinion because you can't
passport services and be part of the
service function of you if you just left
the EU without paying for it will be
that they will change the laws and how
we can service our clients around around
the EU so it for today we can service
you companies here freely with systems
technology research investment banking
sales and training we could do it here
after a brexit we cannot do it all here
and we will have to start playing for
that I don't know if it means a thousand
jobs 2,000 jobs it could be as many as
4,000 and they would be jobs both all
around the UK and as you know the most
important thing for me is we're going to
take care of our people we're going to
take care of our people and we take care
of our clients
I don't want you to worry about it but
when you vote you should be thinking
about something like that and so this is
really important we're really thrilled
that the Chancellor came to be here
today with us and
and I joined that there was a very
important thing whatever happened with
JP Morgan's gonna do her best to help
the people of the UK and the EU but I
please think really carefully about this
decision